welcome back to our s with me is the
Royal historian author Tessa dun Royal
biographer and expert Tom bow and the
Royal expert and author of Charles II
new king new court Robert har we're just
comparing who's are more number ones
bestselling books I came in at three uh
Rob obviously with his first one I think
yeah uh I've had one one more that got
to number one so two and then in came B
with six congratulations I couldn't be
less happy for
you all right let's let's talk Robert
you've written this amazing book it is a
it's a magnificent book about the new
king you could never have predicted when
you wrote this that within 17 months he
would be facing such a serious challenge
not just to his his Reign but to his
life no I mean he he always seemed uh um
someone who's very abstemious I mean
over all the years I I've been following
writing about him even made a program
with him once uh you know here's someone
who's very fit for his age lives a very
abstemious life doesn't drink much uh is
almost fastidious
healthy to the point doesn't even eat
lunch actually thinks lunch is bad for
you um and uh and and and is very fit
and and there can't be many people who
SE have celebrated a 70th birthday with
both parents still alive so you know do
you have any inkling from your many
great sources about what this cancer
actually is no I'm I'm I'm not privy to
to to to the sort of but it must be
serious for them to be taking the action
they're taking I all cancer you know is
serious I I I'm what I what I am hearing
is that he's proving to be not a very
good patient and that he is still
expecting to have all the paperwork
coming all the all the stuff all the the
non public interaction stuff is
continuing um when I was doing the book
I mean you know you talk to people who
who have or do work for him and he does
he keeps very late hours I mean he is he
is a hard worker he has you know Tom
will know Tom's written about you know
some of his padillos and uh and and over
the years he's had a had an
extraordinary life I mean a unique life
but the one thing that that that runs
through it is that whether at good times
or bad um he has this capacity to he
likes mountains of paper uh another
another thing that I think we've all
been so busy over the years um studying
his interest in other faiths you know
the long-standing thing about him
wanting to be a defender of faith that I
don't think we've paid much attention to
his own faith and that actually is is
much deeper and stronger I discovered
anyway than I was aware of uh and and I
think that's something that's going to
stand probably never more important than
it is right now absolutely Tessa let's
talk about uh the inevitable Harry's
flown in he had a 40 minute maximum
meeting with his father that might be it
we don't know maybe he flies back again
um no sign of any reproach M with his
brother I mean what do you make of this
um I think that Harry's been itching to
build Bridges with his father really
from the the birthday call at the back
end of last year I think the omed scobby
book scuppered any Bridges being built
before Christmas and I think that Harry
as quick as he was out of the traps is
indicative of a son who wants to find a
way back in certainly with his father
against Tom he's never really had the
beef the beef was always predominantly
he did attack his father's wife in his
book me it wasn't it wasn't pretty and
I'm sure pretty as ugly as it gets I
mean if one of my family left to me they
would be done I mean Tom we've talked a
lot about this but what do you make of
this this grandiose Gest year I mean on
one level you could say well it shows it
must be a serious situation because he
didn't fly two weeks ago when Charles
had his benign prostate procedure but
he's flown straight in here that does
suggest to me it must be serious but
this Rift with William looks pretty
implacable if you can't come together at
a moment like this when can you well I
as I said last night to you I was very
suspicious about the dash and I won't be
surprised at all as I hinted yesterday
he flies back tonight or tomorrow I
think it was all just for show I think
that it was an impromptu way of getting
attention I think he's a very suspicious
man he's wrote his book for money he's
been very disloyal and I'd be very
surprised if he met Camila when he met
the father when he met his father and I
think the only person he might meet but
now would be uh beatric or Eugene but
otherwise he'll go back and I think that
there's absolutely no hint of
reconciliation his wife is the most
bitter unreconciled woman there is he'll
be told that in any case there's no
future for him and I'm told that
Williams real rage is about what Harry
wrote about his he's right but he's
abely right what he wrote was actually
grotesque only for money yeah and and
he's been terrible about his father as
well I but I don't think we we should be
too suspicious about a son wanting to
have contact with his aging ill father I
think that is a a very simple familial
transaction whatever wat's gone under
the bridge I think it's all too easy to
cast dispersions and one hopes that
Charles is is lar are cast because of
the track record of Harry and his wife
in the last four five he dashed up after
the coronation he was pretty but they
haven't missed a chance to sell sell
trash about their family and not only
that he's he briefed om scobby for the
second book which was a disgraceful book
we discussed that at the time he would
he wouldn't he he would have got it in
the neck if he hadn't come I mean you
said earlier you know damned if he does
damned if he doesn't I think um the the
the jury stays out until we see how uh
you know this this trip is over does he
use it as an opportunity to grab stand
or is it what does the king really feel
about this situation with Harry and also
about the situation between his two sons
with Harry it's door is always open
territory it's it's he is forgiving he
is not one to to Feud on this I think he
much rather uh take a a bit of a hit and
and and and have a much more normal
relationship when it comes to the the
brothers I think he views it as look I
that's for William I can't sort of step
in here about cam Camila and all this
because she's had to step up now not
just with the duty she's performing may
take on some of the Kings but also this
is the love of her life who is facing
this enormous personal Health Challenge
sure but as you know pis Camila is a a
broad shouldered woman she's a mother
herself things get complicated we know
that Harry retreated into his bedroom he
well I'm really talk to you actually
about CH her her feelings about what's
going on with Charles all right well I
think what's interesting about Camila is
the way which she's risen to the
occasion she's had these solo events she
looks impeccable you doesn't even look
like she's having this sort of personal
storm going on in her private life and I
think that this will reframe her in many
ways and it will also I think help set
the tone for Harry's re-entry they all
those two they're mature adults Camila
and Charles they want this Tom one thing
is for sure they will know better than
anybody that you can be very disliked by
the British public and bring things back
they're both massively more popular
Charles and CA than they were in the
aftermath of Diana's you're assuming
Harry wants to come back I don't believe
that for not I don't think he wants so I
don't think Megan wouldn't dream of
wanting to live in rainy London she
loves California and that's where their
life is and I think he just felt I mean
you know this's a man who a couple of
weeks ago went to Jamaica which he knew
is a sensitive spot just to stir up
publicity just to earn some more money
and caused a lot of trouble for Britain
there you know that couple are just
they're intent on causing trouble that
is their meal ticket Tom I don't think
that we should cast everything they do
through the prism of Great Britain I
judge should judge them
on and their actions have been extremely
damaging to the monarchy the royal
family and to this country so if they
change their behavior I'm prepared to
change my view of them and the criticism
Robert just just finally this is a big
thing for the country to deal with this
again coming so soon after the Queen's
death Prince Phillip's death you've got
Kate who's just been in hospital
Fergie Duchess of York has had two bats
of can now it's it's a tough time if
people who like me and you love the
royal family and the monarchy it is a
tough time and it's it's it's you know
come at just as the monarchy had sort of
Consolidated itself I mean he had
enormous shoes to fill King Charles you
know I mean and and a lot of people
predicted it was going to be a uphill
challenge he would stray off into
politics he will blunder here and there
there' be a rise in republicanism that
hasn't been I think the monarchy is is
is in a very solid place I think he's
done a good job in less than a year and
a half of consolidating it and Along
Comes this but he's had plenty of other
shocks that Beyond his control I mean
when you think of uh you know not just
two rounds of the crown plus the Harry
Megan's Netflix thing plus there's
always there's always something Saga of
of of Andrew and and not to mention we
haven't even gotten to republicanism in
the other Realms and all that and yet we
up until last week we weren't really
thinking about the monarchy because it
was doing what it always does it was it
had got boring which is where it be
listen we've run we've run out of time
but if you want to know more about the
monarchy read this new king new court
Charles II the inside story of the
Inside Man Robert har great to see you
congratulations great to see you too
thank you very
much